Feminism is being strong, powerful and confident in who you are.
I define feminism as a woman's right to choose, a woman's right to be free,...
...to be equal to her counterpart.
Change for the better for women would be more opportunities.
I think there could be more equality in workforces.
I think women should encourage other women not see as competition.
They can be mothers.
They can be businesswomen.
They can be students.
They can be dancers.
They can be anything they set their minds to.
A woman is a strong human being that is capable of anything.
Anything.
Anything they want.
Women are capable of anything.
Women are capable of everything.
We could do anything.
Girl power.
We run the world.